good afternoon everyone my name is
adrian dix i'm bc's minister of health
i'm here to my right with dr bonnie
henry bc's provincial health officer
this is uh
our update on clovid19 and we're here to
uh
dr henry will be giving a presentation
and to answer your questions uh we're
honored to be here on the territory of
the la quang and speaking people of the
sangies and the esquimalt first nations
and with that it's my honor to introduce
dr bonnie henry
thank you very much and good afternoon
so today we're going to
give an update on where we are with
covert 19 and go through some of the
data and talk about the measures that
we're going to have
coming up
in the next few days and weeks
and where we are today it should be no
surprise to most people we're in a
reasonably good place since i last
provided an update in in march we have
continued to see progress that is in the
right direction
transmission hospitalizations and deaths
are all down since our last report
and this is encouraging our approach has
always been to only have the minimum
necessary restrictions to keep our
communities safe and now we're at a time
where we can progress
from legally enforceable community
requirements to a place of collective
being able to manage this together
we are transitioning from having all of
our safety levels all of the time to
requiring some of them depending on the
situation that we were in
depending on our risk at each time
and on top of the very core protection
that we have from vaccination and we can
see
that uh close to sixty percent of
children five to eleven over ninety
percent of adults in british columbia
have received at least two doses of
vaccine
and
close to 60 percent have received their
booster dose this is important this
level of immunity and protection that we
have as a population means that we can
move ahead with some other steps
before i get into the data though i
would like to take a moment to
acknowledge
that we have lost now over 3000 people
to covet in the course of this pandemic
here in british columbia
these are our mothers our fathers our
aunties our friends our loved ones
even though we are in a much better
place today
i know that many families are dealing
with the loss of their loved one and
that they've had to deal with this
during the this global pandemic has been
a very challenging challenging time
and i would like you to know that our
thoughts and our prayers are with you as
well
as we've seen in the last little while
hospitalizations and deaths in british
columbia continue to decline
we know that the
that the
the cases in green in this slide um
peaked in early january and have come
down steadily they have leveled off
leveled off at a relatively low level
and i do need to reflect that this is
pcr-positive cases not everybody who's
had covet as we know many people now are
using rapid tests and are being able to
self-diagnose in the community and take
the measures they need without ending up
having severe illness and ending up in
hospital so we have been following as
well our hospitalizations and trends
over time again
are slowly coming down and have been
leveling off a little bit but we need to
look a little bit more in depth of what
who is being hospitalized
in our communities across bc as you know
we move to to reporting hospitalization
as a census so it's everybody who's in
hospital with the positive cova test and
it continues to be that about half of
those people are people who there who
are in hospital with an incidental test
so it's not because of kova that they
are in hospital it is still important to
acknowledge that
they need to be treated differently in
some ways because
covet requires other precautions in
hospital
we continue to see thankfully a very low
death rate
one of the things that we have started
very early on is using other
surveillance measures to help us
understand the impact of this virus on
communities and one of the ones that has
been proven to be extremely helpful is
the wastewater surveillance that we
started in
in 2020 and we can see that this
reflected very well what we're seeing in
communities and it's not dependent on
the number of people who are tested
we have seen a
decrease a steady decrease over the last
few months
and a leveling off once again not quite
at the low levels that we were seeing
prior to the omicron wave but close to
those
but in the last week to two weeks we
started to see a slight uptick in
wastewater surveillance as well and that
reflects again the fact that we have
opened up that we are seeing more uh
transmission in the community even as
hospitalizations and severe illness
continue to decline
one of the other things that we've been
watching very carefully from the
beginning is using whole genome
sequencing to help us understand what
strains of the virus are causing illness
in our community and we can see from
this that
that darker shade of red is the omicron
ba 0.2 we have had predominantly the ba1
and then
early on we had a subset called the ba
1.1 and now about 70 to 75 percent of
our cases are ba 0.2 that's important
because that
does help us understand why we're seeing
a slight uptick in cases and it's partly
because we see from global
data that the va point to is more
infectious and can spread more easily it
does not seem to however to cause more
severe illness particularly in people
who've been immunized and so that's an
important consideration as well
so when we look at who are the people
who are more likely to end up in
hospital and are there measures that we
can take to help mitigate and prevent
them from
having that severe illness
we can see over time that it is our
elders and seniors who are more likely
to have severe illness and end up in
hospital and we see that continues with
people over age 80 through this omicron
wave
also being more likely to have more
severe disease and that has leveled off
and has a slight uptick in the last week
also when we look at this we can see how
younger people are less likely to end up
in hospital so if we break this down a
little bit further and look at
vaccination status so this helps us
understand
whether we're seeing breakthrough cases
in people who've been immunized and
particularly in people who've received
their booster dose or two doses of
vaccine whether there's a need for an
additional dose and here in bc we can
see that people who have had their
booster dose up to age 70 have very
strong protection against severe disease
and this reflects again how
the timing of the booster dose the fact
that most people received it within the
last few few months and that it gives
good strong protection against severe
illness across all age groups and a
reminder for those people who have had
two doses of vaccine if you've not yet
had your booster it is important
we see it is incredibly important as you
get older and people over age 70
it does give good strong protection but
we're seeing some waning of that
protection in the last few weeks and
particularly people over age 80 in our
communities with that booster dose still
have a risk that is higher than every
other age group
except for young people who are
unvaccinated
so if we look at the cumulative
hospitalization rate over this omicron
wave we can see that it has
differentially impacted people over age
70 and particularly people who are over
age 80 and that's one of the the most
vulnerable areas that we can make a
difference right now
if we look at
the age standardized hospitalization the
need for critical care and death rates
across the board we see that people who
are unvaccinated have a much higher risk
of being hospitalized having severe
illness ending up in critical care or
dying and that that booster dose makes a
tremendous difference and what we call
this is age standardized that means
comparing a 50 year old who's
unvaccinated versus a 50 year old who
has three doses of vaccine and that
protection that you get from that
from two or three doses of vaccine is
apparent across all of the critical care
markers
the two most important factors that we
know and this bears out again and again
our age and vaccination status and only
one of these we can control we have no
control over our age but we can control
our vaccination status and reduce our
risk and it reduces not only our risk as
an individual but it helps reduce our
risk of
being infected and transmitting it to
others and on a population basis that
means we have protection in our
community from various strains of this
variant
from omicron and from whatever comes
next
if we look at
our trajectory over the last little
while compared to other jurisdictions we
have been able to flatten our
hospitalization curve and draw it out
which is really important that helps
preserve our health care system so that
everybody who needs it can access it and
so we can reduce the pressure on health
care workers in the system and we see
that we have a very similar
low rate compared to other international
jurisdictions
also see a slight increase
in the last few weeks
not as much as apparent in in other
jurisdictions in canada or
internationally but something that we
need to pay attention to
i also want to
present a little bit of the data on the
zero prevalence studies so we've been
doing these and reporting on them
regularly since march of 2020 and this
helps us understand using
samples of blood from people at
different age groups in our community
how many people have antibodies to the
virus
and antibodies because of vaccination
so there's one antibody called the
nucleocapsid protein and if we have
antibodies to that that means we've been
exposed to the virus and have developed
the antibodies to that specific part of
the virus so means you've been infected
with the virus
not everybody who's infected get sick
with it but you can develop these
antibodies and it's a marker of recent
infection because they tend to fade away
over time the second antibodies one
called the s
and that could be either from being
infected with the virus or from
vaccination and what we can see is over
this course of the pandemic
particularly in the last month with the
omicron wave that we've had we now have
a very high level of people in our pop
population across the board that have
antibodies to both the s protein and
some to the nuclear capsule protein that
tells us
that there's a level of of protection
not perfect because we don't have a a
marker but how much of the antibody you
need but it does tell us that
vaccination and sub subsequent infection
in some people means that we have a high
level of potential immunity in our
community right now that is different
from any other phase that we've been
through in this pandemic
when we take that into account and we
look at the things that are happening
right now with increasing activity with
people traveling more with the slightly
more transmissible variant that we're
seeing cause infections we know that we
are likely to see a slight increase over
time in the next month to two months and
then a gradual decreasing again if we
continue to do the things that we're
doing
and particularly to make sure that we're
we're keeping up to date with our
vaccinations
the other things that we are looking at
and the data i presented says what can
we do to help reduce this potential for
increase in hospitalizations and that's
looking at who is most at risk and can
we provide them with a booster dose that
will prevent that from happening and i
today we're announcing that in
that looking at this data we are going
to be offering a spring booster for
elders and seniors in british columbia
as the people being most at risk we know
that the older we are the more uh the
sooner that antibodies will wane and
this the less strong our cell mediated
those memory cell responses will be so
an extra booster dose right now
will provide a rapid increase in
antibodies and we've seen that from data
in other countries where this has been
used and will provide that spring
protection as we're able to get
back to more activities in the community
so it will be available to
uh we'll be providing it to residents of
long-term care at any age
and assisted living and for community
seniors 70 and over across the board in
british columbia as well as for
indigenous people at age 55 and older
and the
fourth dose will be at a boat six months
from your first booster dose or the dose
3.
in addition we've always had a different
program we've recognized that there are
a group of people
who are what we call clinically
extremely vulnerable and we know that
they needed three doses of vaccine to
get the protection that most people have
from two and several months ago we also
put in a booster dose program for that
group of people so a dose four at about
six months and right about now is when
many people who are in that cev group
one into the immune compromising
conditions will be receiving their dose
for as well
so this is going to be a really
important measure for us to boost the
immunity in those most vulnerable to
severe illness and hospitalization as we
go into these spring months
along with that with this level of of
community immunity that we have now we
are in a position where we continue to
make progress and removing some of the
measures that are no longer necessary
all the time
one of those is that the bc vaccine card
which was very effective at supporting
people to get vaccinated but also during
this highest risk period
being able to to have these measures in
place in those highest risk settings
so it is no longer required under order
so no longer a legal order but we do
know that many businesses are looking at
their own clientele and their own
people who
go into theaters and movie theaters and
some will continue to require
this as well businesses will transition
from coveted safety plans to
communicable disease plans and these
were the plans that that got us through
much of 2021 and we reinstated those
cove specific safety plans early on in
the omicron wave when we still didn't
understand exactly what
the the conditions were going to be with
omicron so we're now going back to those
safety plans still being aware in every
workplace of the risks and the measures
that are important to be in place to
reduce the risk to workers in all of
those situations
finally we'll be removing the
post-secondary residence vaccine
requirement
we have seen that there are very high
rates of immunization in young people
particularly young people who are living
in residence in post-secondary
institutions and so this was not felt to
be required anymore
just to go back for a minute to the
spring boosters i wanted to reiterate
how important it is for all of us to
ensure that we are up to date with our
vaccines and that means now getting a
booster dose
we are seeing a leveling off in
transmission but that doesn't mean our
province is no longer
vulnerable to new and potential variants
that are coming in the future
it's important for us to address the
risk we have now but also to think ahead
we're still in a transition phase and
we're still in this pandemic and we
still have a lot of uncertainty what's
coming next
people who don't have the protection
that vaccine gives are at the highest
risk no matter what your age
and more and more data shows us that the
booster dose at all ages decreases
transmission doesn't eliminate it
completely but even with omicron even
with the ba 0.2 it reduces that risk of
infection across the board and provides
as we've found a very strong protection
against hospitalization
icu and death
so now is the time to get your booster
if you've had omicron in the last few
months
you can wait up to three months but we
know that the
booster dose does give you longer and
stronger lasting protection even if
you've had
omicron recently
i think it's important to recognize as
well that we are transitioning from
these broad societal orders
where we needed all of these measures
all of the time
but it's not all or nothing we need to
learn to live with covet 19 better to
make sure that we continue our good
habits that protect us our family and
our community
i also want to say and we've been
talking about this on and off for the
last
number of weeks
but we will be transitioning from the
daily
numbers reporting to weekly reporting
starting this thursday april 7th what
that means is that we will be able to
automatically link data and have more
in-depth and detailed accurate reporting
of numbers
of the previous week to get people a
better sense of what we what we expect
to see and what the risk profile is we
have as we've seen especially during
omicron when it was very challenging to
keep up with the daily
manual line lists
we see various swings on a day-to-day
basis so we now have an automated
process that allows us to do it in a
more accurate and timely way as well
we'll be transitioning to a new way of
reporting people who've died from covet
and it's going to be looking at 30-day
all-cause mortality in anybody who has
had a covet-positive test so that means
we will be over counting people early on
because we know that it takes
several days for the linkage to happen
between our lab tests and
vital statistics but then as we get the
cause of death data in from vital
statistics that will be updated on a
rolling basis and that gives us a more
accurate picture of all cause impacts
from covet 19.
i do want to just quickly update about
the regulated health professionals order
i do want to also say that the changes
in use of the bc vaccine card and this
order have no bearing on the
requirements that we continue to have
for all healthcare professionals in our
public health care system to be
vaccinated that requirement has been
incredibly important in protecting our
health care system through this wave and
is important for helping us make sure
we're ready for what comes in the future
but we have been working with the 18
regulated health profession colleges to
gather data on vaccine status of every
regis registrant and the deadline for
this was march 31st and the colleges are
actively doing that right now
we have goods
data on most people but they are
continuing to follow up on individuals
who may have been
on vacation or maternity leave and other
things our team is now actively
compiling this aggregated vaccination
data by profession and i will be
reporting that out by profession so
people will have an understanding of
the vaccination levels in different
professions in the community and can
make their own informed decisions about
their own care based on that
we are also working with the colleges
and will be over the next few weeks and
months to put in place processes based
on risk
so that people will have informed
consent about whether they want to
receive a procedure or a health care
service from a private practitioner
who's vaccinated or not
i do want to say as well that we are
working very hard to integrate all of
our surveillance pieces and although we
we report out on a regular basis on a
number of things we are following a
number of other surveillance streams
including a population what we call
sentinel surveillance we've had this in
place for many years for influenza and
we're integrating covet into that so
that we can look at all of the serious
respiratory illnesses that we have to
deal with and manage uh in the future so
that includes things like influenza
covid rsv and para influenza
we're looking at we will be and continue
to do facility facility-based monitoring
of cases and outbreaks we're expanding
our systematic early morning signals
through wastewater to areas outside of
the lower mainland this has proven to be
a really helpful
objective surveillance measures so we'll
be expanding it across the province and
also expanding the number of pathogens
that we can look for
using this wastewater water techniques
that we've perfected over the last two
years
we'll be continuing to do more frequent
targeted serological surveillance so
that's looking for those antibodies in
the blood that i've mentioned i'm doing
it in a
shorter time frame that helps us
understand the transmission of the
different respiratory viruses
over time and we'll be continuing with
our whole genome sequencing as we've
seen how helpful it is in helping us
understand the different transmission
patterns of the different variants that
are affecting people in british columbia
as we progress forward
through this phase of our pandemic a
transition phase we are in a place where
we can go from those mandated
requirements
to managing things with the good
managing our own health looking at the
good habits that help us protect
ourselves our family and our communities
covet 19 transmission continues but at a
much lower level and with a much higher
level of community protection right now
but we know that that will wane over
time so we need to to build these habits
and these tools in that we have now into
our
future as well these good habits include
the importance of keeping up to date on
our vaccination
and that means right now a spring
booster dose for our elders and seniors
and long-term care and in the community
but we will be watching and looking at
different variants that arise what might
our future be in terms of next
respiratory season late summer and
spring and fall it may be that we will
recommend a booster dose for more people
it may be that we will need another
booster dose for those who are most at
risk
it means paying attention to how we are
feeling and staying home if we're sick
using rapid tests to help us make those
decisions about whether it is covet
that's causing our illness or not
it means wearing a mask when we choose
or if somebody asks you to or if you're
entering their home or their business
it's about also knowing our own comfort
levels and respecting that of others
we need to pay attention to things like
ventilation about
the things that help us enable us to do
this like paid sick leave
there is no magic moment to lift
restrictions and there's no amount of
delaying
that will make it absolutely safe
all the time
so it is something that we need to find
this balance and i believe as we're
transitioning through this we have the
tools that we know work we have
vaccination we have the things that we
are getting used to being in the habit
of doing like staying away when we're
sick like wearing a mask when it's
appropriate
this is our time to to walk through this
transition together and i want to thank
everybody across the province for doing
their part for so long it has been a
most challenging time and we are not
through it yet but your kindness and
compassion has made the difference in so
many ways
and we need to keep doing this together
through this phase and as we get to
the next phase in the spring and fall
thank you very much
thank you very much dr henry and i
wanted to
just start by
joining
dr henry and thanking all
the healthcare workers across bc for
their extraordinary work during this
pandemic
one of the areas where this work has
been
exceptional has been
our vaccination campaigns across bc
and uh yesterday we passed 10 million
appointments booked eleven million five
hundred and six thousand and ninety
eight uh vaccines administered
four million five hundred and twenty
nine thousand 770 first doses 4 358 529
second doses 2 million
677
580 booster doses to date and as dr
henry has noted
that effort not only continues but is
significantly expanded today beyond even
the recommendations of the national
advisory committee on immunization i
want to put in context the significance
of this that is focused as you can see
by the evidence before us that there are
um at present
595
943 people over 70 who've received their
booster or third dose
and those that group of people as they
approach
the interval period will be eligible for
an additional booster dose that's
significant
in addition
to that there are in the category of
clinically vulnerable described by dr
henry those who received
their third dose not a boosters but the
completion of their
their course of covet-19
vaccines last fall that's about a
hundred thousand people in those
categories those people who have
our immunity
suppressed and have access and of course
the work that will be going on over the
next month in april in long-term care
where essentially all long-term care
homes received
the the option of getting covet-19 not
like homes but people in the homes do
the option of getting a coven-19
pandemic
vaccine
booster vaccine in the month of october
april is six months from then and so we
will be
at all long-term care homes uh the
vaccine campaign in the month of april
and finally just like to reiterate a
very important point about booster doses
there are over 70 currently 68 221
people
over 70
who haven't received their booster dose
and who are eligible for that dose and i
would strongly encourage them today to
go on the get vaccinated website or to
call one eight
eight
eight three three eight three eight two
three two three and book their
appointment today at the hundreds of
that pharmacies that are currently
taking appointments
for example
it is it is more than ever
important for this group of people to
get that first booster dose and i
encourage all of them to get it and i
encourage
the 1 million 198 000 people in bc who
are eligible for their booster doses to
do the same it is important in these
times it is a critical protection
evidence shows that i encourage everyone
to do that and i want to thank all those
involved in community pharmacy for all
their continued work on this issue i
want to give a an update on rapid tests
and and to let you know about a change
in the way we'll be distributing rapid
tests in the coming weeks
as of april 1st bc has received 15
million 317
800 rapid test
40 million 145 396 tests have been
deployed to key strategic areas as
presently noted just over half a million
tests in our inventory are not suitable
for deployment or personal use
[Music]
and are being used at the discretion of
medical health officers in the
appropriate settings that leaves a
current inventory of nine million six
hundred and twenty six thousand eight
hundred and sixty tests
suitable for self-administered use
but in context the date 4.4 million
tests have been distributed to k-12
schools across the province 2.13 million
tests have been distributed to
post-secondary institutions and nine
million testaments are delivered to more
than thirteen hundred pharmacies across
bc
tests for british columbians age
eighteen plus and older to pick up a kit
containing five tests a participating
pharmacy and as of yesterday pharmacies
have dispensed
4.93 million tests that's more than 800
000 people have picked up their tests
from that source that's in addition to
the tests have been distributed through
the education system and many other
places our inventories in the province
remain sufficient to handle expected
demand
over the next month
starting october april 8th therefore
people can access rapid tests at
pharmacies with no care card required
for more information on accessing test
kits british columbians can visit
bcpharmacy.ca to make sure pharmacy has
test kits it's important to remember
that testing continues to be something
we do when we have symptoms that hasn't
changed
increased test availability means more
members of the general public will be
able to access tests to use to
understand their own symptoms and
illness and to take action to limit
transmission to their friends family and
work including those
at higher risk
and now here's our weekly surgical
renewal update
the week of march 27
27 to april 2nd marks the first week
since september in which there were no
surgical postponements due to covet 19.
health authorities report that
6983 surgeries were completed march 6 to
march 12th that's similar to what we saw
uh in advance of the before the pandemic
it's a significant number of surgeries
and it's even more impressive for the
fact this is very close to that number
very close to the number we did in that
same week in 2019
as we noted in may 2020 when we made our
surgical renewal commitment and as i
reiterated last november when surgeries
are postponed because of covet it also
means that surgeries aren't booked and
that's why taking care
why taking care of these past few weeks
by all of you has been so critical and
why getting vaccinated continues to be
critical to reducing that
hospitalizations judakovit and the
number of people with covet in our icus
so that we can get give all those
involved in delivering surgeries every
opportunity they need to do the work
we're counting on them to do
when we know someone who's had their
surgery or we know someone who's now
received their call to rebook their
surgery each of us can i think
appreciate how meaningful this
achievement is for everyone each surgery
is life-changing for the patient who
receives it
and to that and to this end i'll be
continuing to meet with all those
involved in delivering surgeries and all
surgical division organizations as we
renew strengthen and rebuild and move
forward with our surgical renewal
commitment and continue to fulfill our
promises to patients
since our last briefing since the
lifting of mandates and easing of
restrictions i think each of us going at
our own pace and adapting to those
changes has continued to make a
difference by taking care in our actions
and considerations to stop the rapid
spread of covet it is by taking care by
doing what we know works to keep those
us and those around us safe that we
continue to give ourselves the much
needed opportunity to safely renew
i think for all of us i want to say and
i just want to say in conclusion how
much i appreciate and continue to
appreciate the commitment of british
columbians and the generosity of people
in this province we need to continue to
keep steps to support one another and to
keep ourselves safe
this pandemic
throughout its course and this virus
which doesn't care
about our about
anything but transmitting will have
[Music]
as people will know we're in the
basement of the legislature we're
occasionally interrupted by bells which
is uh for people who work here i think
generally a positive thing so i'll just
say that but it we it also uh
it clearly is a virus that doesn't care
care about bells any more than it cares
about sometimes our divisions
in society around some of these
questions here in bc
with 94 percent of adults vaccinated
with the support we've given one another
we have i think
demonstrated the best possible response
to covet 19 as a community and i want to
thank british columbians for doing that
there will be more surprises and
challenges in the months to come i know
we are up to that and we are going to
continue to keep you informed about the
kovid 19 pandemic as we go forward and
with that i'm happy to take your
questions
thank you a reminder to media on the
line please press star one to enter the
queue for a chance to ask a question and
a follow-up our first question today
will come from the room richard zessman
global news uh you mentioned some
businesses may want to keep the vaccine
card based on their clientele what sort
of businesses are those and
what is the recommendation for
businesses who put in vaccine
requirement for their employees based on
your advice should they
continue to keep that vaccine
requirement in place for their workers
yeah so two very different issues the
vaccine card was in place as you know to
um
the requirement was in certain places to
ensure that only vaccinated people
attended those higher risk indoor
settings so i know i've talked with some
business owners who own restaurants for
example
community restaurants where they feel
that they're going to keep that
requirement for a period of time we know
as well that some
smaller shops that can get more crowded
they also want to keep requirements for
mask wearing or for
people to
to have be vaccinated and we've seen
that in theaters in
museums and places where it actually
wasn't required so each business has to
do their own due diligence and has to
make sure they have the ability to
accommodate people
who aren't vaccinated whether that's
doing takeaway or being able to watch
things remotely so it is about doing
your own due diligence but that is still
there for people to use
depending on their own safety protocols
in terms of vaccine mandates for
workplaces again
my recommendations have been focused on
the health system and we continue to
have that in place in the health system
recognizing how important it is as we're
going through again
there will be more uncertain times in
the future to make sure we all have that
protection and i know a number of
different uh
businesses organizations including the
public service agency did again their
due diligence about the risk and what
positions were
had risk in their
different settings and again that is up
to each business to make sure that
they've done their own due diligence and
they have the processes in place that
meet the requirements of their own
collective agreements and other
employee employer agreements
around long-term care visitations
no changes announced today on that when
should we expect to see some changes
around how many people can come to
long-term care i'm just hoping for
minister dicks also to provide clarity
around the announcement about rapid
testing
if it now includes all ages can access
rapid tests or will still be done
through schools and how quickly so just
those two things
in long-term care we have opened up
visitation and long-term care so that
vaccinated visitors of any number can
come
we do have requirements for rapid
testing particularly when people start
to come in and we're looking at what is
a rational policy for
for ongoing rapid testing of visitors
particularly regular visitors where we
don't necessarily need to have a test
every single day and now that we have
access people can do them at home um
prior to visitation so that uh that is
ongoing
and uh with respect to rapid tests we
have about 50 million
with us
about 40 million have been distributed
about 9 million have been distributed to
pharmacies
to pick them up you have to be 18 and
older so that continues to be the case
what's changing is right now
you're limited within a period and what
you can pick up you know it'll be still
one at a time but you have to give your
medical services card number and that
number is tracked after april the 11th
that won't happen any further we'll
simply distribute them it saves
pharmacy costs it saves us costs and it
reflects the numbers of rapid tests we
have
it should be said that and i really
encourage people to go in the meantime
and get their rapid tests from
pharmacies because
it's a useful tool for people to have
the ones i picked up a number of weeks
ago expire i think in january 2024
meaning that i won't necessarily need to
use them right away but it's good to
have them in stock in our household have
them there and so
in terms of schools we've sort of
distributed through the school system a
very significant amount but we hold
rapid tests on hand and we'll be able to
keep that
keep people in the education system
with rapid test parents and children and
their community
with rapid tests into the future the
federal government has generally
indicated they continue going to
continue to supply them and so we're
distributing them um broadly right now
and
and really everyone in bc every adult in
bc
every school-aged child in bc
has access now to rapid tests they can
simply put to pick them up for free and
that's a pretty as broad access as we
can get we encourage people to pick them
up and
and there are rapid tests available
today at your pharmacies and there are
vaccinations available to be booked and
i encourage people to get looked for
their vaccinations
our next question comes from zhao zhu
global male
thanks for taking my question uh quebec
and pei have put a pause on lifting
their mask mandates with removing math
requirements done prematurely in bc and
what metric would bc need to meet before
you re-implement masks
yeah so
we have
always thought a lot about risks and
benefits when you have a legal mandate
in place
so we removed that as you know a number
of weeks ago
given what we were seeing in terms of
the high level of vaccination and the
low levels of transmission it's now it's
not an all or nothing
proposition however and we still
encourage people to wear masks
particularly in those indoor
spaces when you're close to people that
you don't know
where you might be have poor ventilation
or crowding so we still strongly
encourage that for people to choose to
do that but we no longer feel it's
necessary to have a legal order that
requires you to wear it all the time
every day in those settings and
particularly we know it impacted
children and staff in schools and
post-secondary institutions
and people who are also
affected by many other measures so we
are
perfectly we believe that we had the
right time
for removing the mass mandate we've seen
a continued decrease in in transmission
and that people are being respectful of
requirements and requests to wear masks
xiao do you have a follow-up
yes i do thanks
the uptake of third doses was low how do
you expect the uptake of fourth uh shot
to go and uh if the vaccine passport was
uh useful in propelling our second doses
uh why get rid of it wouldn't it do the
same for uh third shots
yeah
it is one measure but it is only one
measure that can
incentivize people to be immunized and
that was one of the uh the ways we use
the bc vaccine card uh and it was quite
effective in that
um on the other hand it there are uh
downsides to the bc vaccine card
so we are
um
there and i'm just sorry i lost your the
first part of your
question
zhao would you mind repeating i'm sorry
oh sorry yeah uh the uptake of uh third
shots was low how do you expect the
uptake of four shots to go well this is
a very targeted program it's targeted at
those people who we know and we
presented the data at are most at risk
of having waning immunity most of them
have had
their third other their booster their
first booster so their third shot
and their the level of protection is
waning over time so i expect that we are
going to see a high uptake of the fourth
dose in seniors and elders i will also
say that when we look at our zero
prevalence that i presented and it shows
a high rate of exposure to the virus in
or developing of antibodies in younger
people but a very low rate in older
people so people over age 70 and over
age 80 only about 10 or 11 percent of
them somewhere around there had
antibodies to the virus which means
their protection is from vaccination and
that they we've been done a good job of
protecting them from infection so that
that's the group of people where um we
we need to get that extra booster dose
in to bump up their antibodies bump up
that cell mediated immunity
uh as we're going through this next few
months
and just say that we're talking about
people 70 and above so put this in
context between 94 and 95 percent of
people 17 and above receive their first
dose 92 percent have received their
second dose meaning
uh approximately 97 of those who got
their first dose who got their second
dose
uh with respect to those who've had two
doses 90 of those
70 and above have received their booster
dose which is impressive and we're
expecting because of its value which is
demonstrated by the data and
demonstrated and understood by those
over 70 based on their uptake of the
extraordinary uptake of vaccination in
those categories they understand better
than anybody i believe the value of
vaccination the protection it provides
to them so i don't agree with that
characterization of
of it in fact
there's been excellent uptake amongst
those over 70 and it will be our
expectation as invitations go out over
the next period for people when they
reach
when the interval period passes from the
last booster dose i'm expecting a high
high degree of uptake and of course
there is a very high degree of uptake as
well in long-term care which we expect
to see again
in the month of april as we go through
both the
the vaccination process and what
precedes that and what's going on now
which is
in some cases the requirement for
permission from others so
i think that um i think it's actually
been quite positive and we're uh i'm
optimistic about it there are some areas
of our vaccination program where we
continue to make efforts to see
a higher level of vaccination that
includes
children
5 to 11 for example
but
i think in general
what i'd say to everybody is there are
hundreds
hundreds of community pharmacies
who have appointments open in bc for
booster dose vaccination and i encourage
all of those who haven't got their
booster and that's over the whole
province about 1 million 198 000 of
those who are eligible to get their
booster as soon as possible
our next question comes from bender
sachin ctv
hello there um i'm just wondering if you
can just maybe provide a number in terms
of
community immunity and how many people
you think
have had the virus and also
i know you're talking about spring
boosters for people who are older
clinically extremely vulnerable and
other groups but i'm wondering um do you
anticipate that the second boosters will
be offered to the rest of the
populations as it was as the initial
vaccines were
the the short answer is no at this point
we don't see it progressing beyond those
most at risk right now so it's the
spring booster for those who need it
right now and that's uh seniors and
elders and the data really supports that
um the nasi statement is very similar
the rest of us who have had our booster
already
have good strong protection from that
still so i don't foresee that in the
near future
we don't yet know what's going to happen
when we come up to
late summer early fall
when we expect to be back in respiratory
season and we're looking at the
different scenarios that could happen so
it could be that we'll need
maybe an annual booster maybe it will
just be for people who are most at risk
so those are things that we don't yet
know
that we're planning for the different
scenarios that could happen in the fall
but in the short term the spring boost
is for those who need it most and that's
seniors and elders over the age of 70
and people who who don't mount a strong
immune response because of their
their clinical conditions
in terms of what level of protection we
have from the combination of vaccination
and infection so when i talked about the
percentage of people in the sero
prevalence
there was a percentage of people that
had indication of either or
and it differs by age so across the
board there's probably about 50 percent
of people who have
antibodies to the virus which shows the
nuclear capsid protein which shows that
they had exposure and infection but the
vast majority of those people are
vaccinated so it is a boost to their
vaccine
protection that they have already which
is a good thing it means that most
people didn't have very severe illness
and they have a bit of a boost to their
immunity because they were exposed and
infected with the virus i know
some people still had
got very sick with it
but they didn't end up in hospital
didn't end up in critical care and
that's because they had the protection
from the vaccines whether it was two
doses or more importantly three doses so
that needs to continue we we have seen
though that in the zero to four age
group that group of young people young
children who are not yet eligible for
vaccination we're seeing that
about 50 to 60 percent of that age group
of people have antibodies to the
nucleocapsid which means they've been
exposed to the virus in the recent
few months
and if we look at data from other places
around the world
we also see that omicron does cause
less severe illness in children even
than the previous variants so this is is
a bit of a relief
considering we don't yet have
vaccination for that age group that
omicron is not causing severe illness
for the most part in younger children
and that's
important for us to know i do think it
is important as well to to recognize
that
prevention of infection is important
people who get infected with this virus
can develop long symptoms even if they
don't have very severe illness and long
covet is a very real phenomenon that
affects people and we know that this
virus can affect it can cause
inflammation of the the heart
inflammation of the lining of the heart
of the blood vessels that can lead to
things like strokes and
and heart attacks
that go on for a long time and can leave
people with long lasting effects
thankfully omicron doesn't cause that as
much as as delta in particular but we
don't know what's coming next
what we do know
is that vaccines reduce that risk of
long covert dramatically
some studies show as at least 50 percent
reduction in risk of having long covet
if you're vaccinated with two doses of
vaccine so
this is my plea to people now recognize
that we're in a place right now where we
have a level of immunity we have
decreasing
transmission in our communities but you
need to protect yourself from the risks
of this virus and it will change we've
seen that globally that this virus will
change and so this is our best way of
protecting ourselves for now and for the
future and i just also want to say
because i was going to mention and i
forgot that
novavax which is the protein subunit
vaccine a more traditional
form of vaccine has finally arrived in
canada it's been delayed for a few weeks
and we expect it will be available for
people
either late this week or early next week
i know there's several thousand people
who've
signed up for it already and you'll be
getting in for invites to go to your
local pharmacy to get this as soon as we
get it in place
and if anybody is
interested right now in getting it
either as your first dose your second
dose or a booster dose you can call the
833-838-2323
number
and
put yourself on the list to get that
vaccine when it comes in
binder do you have a follow-up
i do i'm just wondering um when it comes
to rapid tests uh which most people have
access to
um
how good are they at catching like
subsequent
variants um such as va2 hearing
anecdotally people saying that it takes
a couple of days after infection or
after becoming symptomatic to
show up in some cases not showing up at
all so just is there a concern that as
we see different barriers that these
rapid tests may not catch the virus
that was a concern it continues to be a
concern
and this is why they are most useful
when you have symptoms and yes for some
people they may not shed as much virus
or they may not
use it i know we've all probably
experimented with them now they may not
have
done a good enough sample to pick up the
virus
but we're not seeing a difference
between
from what i've been watching from what
our lab tells us not seeing a difference
between ba1 and and ba2 in terms of
being able to pick it up it does
sometimes test there's false positives
but there also is false negatives
especially early on in infection so
if you still have symptoms repeat the
test
but it is also not very helpful and is
less accurate if you don't have symptoms
so if you've been exposed to somebody
and you don't have symptoms yourself the
rapid test doesn't really tell you
anything so again it goes back to what i
talk about you know it's a red light not
a green light
for the next question we go to lisa
cardasco vancouver son
thank you very much um dr henry i just
want to ask about the changes in death
reporting um
when you know subsequently how many
people have died from covid19 because
you said at first there would be an over
uh reporting of that number will that
number of the people who have actually
died from covert 19 be listed as a
separate number or in a separate
category on the dashboard and if not
then how will we know how many people
have actually died from covert 19.
yeah a very good question and what i can
do is is
get our um
the the epidemiologists from the vccdc
to walk through it with anybody who's
interested about how we're going to
how the data is linked and how it is
updated in real time so there will be a
retrospective decreasing and increasing
of numbers as the data is refreshed over
time but it will be automated so right
now when we do that um you you may
recall some days we we've taken off x
number of cases and
because we we do periodic data reviews
now it'll be an ongoing automated data
review um so at the beginning it will
look
uh more awkward than as time goes on
it'll be it'll even out but i can uh i
can reach out to our team and and give
people a technical briefing on what
exactly it's going to look like if you
like
do you have a follow-up lisa
yes thank you um also on the weekly
reporting uh it will be a weekly
reporting of hospitalizations and
whatnot but if there is a spike let's
say one day there's one hospital case
and the next day there's a hundred and
the third day there's 500. how how will
you know that
before a week goes by
since that is a long time if there is a
spike or will you be receiving those
numbers daily but just be posting them
weekly
yeah so
what we do we look at those numbers
every day and they're preliminary
numbers and we get these automatic
preliminary numbers
and
the minister and the team looks at the
overall numbers we we
talk about those sometimes you know
what's the overall census in uh icu how
many people are there in hospital
overall um in which beds
so this is a more
as we went to
as we went to the census reporting of
hospitalizations we get the preliminary
numbers every day and we will continue
to do that we'll continue to monitor
that we get preliminary reports from the
lab linkage about how many people have
tested positive but there's often
duplications in those and so the numbers
that come out one day um will be
overestimates because they were the
cutoff was at nine o'clock instead of
ten o'clock or there was a second
runners things a whole bunch of things
happen on a day-to-day basis that we can
then
once a week look back and get the more
accurate numbers by day so that's how it
will be reporting coming along but we
continue to monitor these things on a
day-to-day basis
just
one second
just uh there the last there will be a
daily report today and tomorrow as we go
into the new weekly thing so you'll get
some information
on or around three o'clock or between
three and four o'clock today and
tomorrow and then after that we'll be
moving to weekly reporting
our next question goes to rob shaw check
news
oh hi um i've listened to you talk about
slide 12
twice in a technical briefing and
publicly i i just
i apologize that this is an
overly simplistic question but when you
look at it
it looks like
there's another wave
of
new daily hospital admissions and that
in the 20 increase scenario you get to
the kind of
almost height of the new daily hospital
admissions that we were at um in you
know mid-january where we were worried
about the stress on the health care
system is that am i reading that wrong
or is that is that their potential that
that happens and
what am i getting wrong about this chart
because i don't i feel like i must have
missed something here so again it's
modeling so it gives us a sense of what
could happen depending on different
scenarios and so some of the things that
this helps us say is
giving this fourth uh spring booster
dose to those who are more likely to be
hospitalized can affect that the
measures that we all take to check
ourselves make sure that
we're feeling well testing if we have
symptoms staying away from others so
that we're not transmitting it
that makes a difference in this wave so
yes it we expect to see a gradual
increase and then a slowing but even
we i talk through these things with the
modelers all the time at the peak with
that 20 percent potential increase we
would expect to see about half the
hospitalizations
at a very slow rate over time so what we
what we saw with the omicron was a very
rapid rise
and then a gradual falling off what this
is predicting is that if we do the
things that we're doing if nothing
changes then we're going to see a
gradual wire
a much slower
and lower rise over time over the next
couple of months and that there are
things that we can do that can affect
this trajectory
rob do you have a follow-up
nope that's good thank you
okay we'll go to mario white and the
thai hi thank you for taking my question
um dr henry earlier in this briefing you
said um that we were still seeing quite
a low
rate of death um in the last three
months we've seen nearly 600 people die
about a fifth of our recorded tools so
far
and as your modeling suggests we're now
on the precipice of a six wave uh
depending on how things go
what's the reasoning behind lifting
protective measures now and how would
you explain that strategy to
people who are vulnerable or elderly and
know that they are at the greatest risk
or diet
yeah i think what we need to do is
put it in a balance and we've talked
about this a lot
you know there are things that we can do
to protect ourselves as individuals and
there's things that we can do that
protect ourselves collectively and the
number one most important one is being
vaccinated and that is it protects you
as an individual
there's a fourth dose available for
those who are most at risk and we know
that that makes a difference so that's
an important protection but we also need
to to
be true to the third goal of our
pandemic response which is minimizing
societal disruption and understanding
that there are negative consequences to
each of the orders each of the actions
that we put in place by legal
requirement so we need to find those
balance and you're right there's no
magic time when there will be zero risks
so we could
keep in place certain things for the
next two weeks and the next month
there still will be no zero risk when we
remove those so we have to find a time
where we know we have strong levels of
immunity in our community right now we
know that people
know what to do that these become part
of our healthy habits that we do to
protect ourselves and our family and
those we're close to particularly
those who are more vulnerable to severe
illness we have that extra booster shot
keeping up to date with our vaccines
those are the things that will get us
through this transition period and i
think it's you know it's it's it's
challenging to know when is the best
time to do things but i think we're in a
place as well where we're moving into
summer we're doing more things outside
there's more opportunities for people to
have those safe interactions
moira do you have a follow-up
i do thank you um dr henry just further
to your note on needing to find that
balance um you know a lot of people i've
spoken to uh who are at a higher risk
despite being you know triple or even
quadruple vaccinated
shortly are just saying they feel like
they're at the end
of what they can accomplish as an
individual and they're worried about
going to the grocery store and
protecting themselves from their
children going to school not wearing
masks with other kids who are you know
in large part not vaccinated either
how
how do you articulate the balance
between
someone losing their life as we're
seeing
multiple people
each day on average or doing in bc
uh and you know
having to wear a mask when you go into
the grocery store like what is the
calculation around
around that balance for you
yeah so i i think
i wrote an op-ed that has some of this
in it as well
i think we also have been through a very
traumatic period of of two years now
where this virus has changed we've
adapted
there are very few people that are at
that very high level of risk anymore and
that's because we've had this
highly effective vaccines
and we know that there are other risks
in our community that we all need to to
pay attention to and the measures that
we're taking are ones that protect us
from other respiratory illnesses from
other infections as well and these are
things that we've always done we've
always had to balance those risks about
what we're seeing what we're exposed to
what our own risk is
and right now with the level of
transmission we're seeing with the
measures that we have in place
grocery stores are not a high risk
environment and we can have the
confidence that we're vaccinated
that we're wearing masks we keep our
respectful distance from people we still
have barriers in place we're paying
attention to things like ventilation
that we can safely do more
but it will be a transition period for
all of us and we'll have to manage that
we'll have to support each other and be
positive in how we do that over the next
few weeks and months
and i just want to note on the issue of
those most vulnerable but i think
one of the things that
that public health in bc
all of our medical health teams and dr
henry
have put at the forefront in everything
that we've done
has been
protect those who are most vulnerable to
covet 19.
it's why we
put forward for vaccination our repeated
clinically vulnerable programs
that were
by the way wildly successful in
responding to the needs of those who are
clinically vulnerable to get vaccinated
first
why we gave priority in terms of
vaccination at every stage including at
the booster dose stage those populations
and to older people why in a very
significant announcement today
we're providing
a second booster
to those most vulnerable and clinically
vulnerable to clovid 19 or a fourth dose
to the clinically vulnerable community
in bc
and that has been
affected our approach to other groups
that have been led by dr henry including
indigenous groups in bc and the work
that has been done by the first nations
health authority by dr ben smith and dr
henry's office
is a demonstration of that
and with respect to access to antivirals
those clinically vulnerable having
priority and with respect to access to
rapid tests so at every step in this
process
priority has been given to those who are
clinically and vulnerable and that
represents not just the medical approach
that public health has taken bc but the
ethical one and it's one that i'm very
proud of them for
we have time for one more question today
we'll go to bell puree cbc
absolutely thank you
just a a reminder as well
of about the fact that we do have
treatments available and we're getting
more of them in particularly paxilvid
which is an antiviral and people are
prioritized by by their own risk and i
encourage people to go to the covit
treatments
website and get more information there's
a process there even if you don't have
access to a family physician where you
can look at your own risk and whether
you're eligible
to receive these treatments
so that's another tool that we have that
can support people and prevent them from
having severe illness and we've had
several thousand people already who've
had either cetrova med or
pax levit in the last few months
sorry about that bell thank you so much
please go ahead with your question
no problem thanks um dr henry if the
strategy now is you know for british
columbians to assess their own risk for
koved and then make their own decisions
based on that you know how do they
assess that risk um accurately if they
only have weekly numbers like you know
when we plan our lives we check the
weather every day not once a week so how
do we
get enough information with only weekly
uh numbers and not daily and in english
and french please yeah so i think that
weather is a very good analogy
the weather does change every day what
we're seeing in terms of risk doesn't
change every day it's more like climate
as opposed to weather what you're seeing
every day
and so yeah it is important to
understand where we are collectively
over time but these are not measures
that
for example wastewater testing we only
do it once a week it's only able to be
done at that frequency it doesn't change
that much over a period of a day or 24
hours and so yes
it is
we need to think of it in a period of a
longer period of time what's my risk
this week what are the things that i
feel comfortable doing
you know next week will shall i go out
to a restaurant with friends this coming
weekend here's how i'm feeling here's
what i know about my friends and whether
they've been exposed to anybody with
covid uh here's how you know on a
day-to-day basis we have to look at how
am i feeling today do i have a scratchy
throat do i have a fever maybe i'll i'll
hold off meeting with
going to visit my grandparents if i'm
not feeling so well today
those are the things that we need to
start building into how we do our
assessment and having a daily number of
people who are
test positive for kovitt is not going to
help us make those decisions in a
in a one-on-one basis on a day-to-day
basis because it doesn't change that
much from day to day
we can get a sense of what's happening
in our communities in the province over
time and a weekly time frame is what
is most reasonable given what we're
seeing with transmission patterns right
now
we effectively
[Music]
[Music]
yes please dr henry the transition phase
we've heard it many times before so you
know how confident are you that this
reprieve from restrictions um
would be permanent this time around
because we hear you say
not through it yet um how long until we
are through it sounds ominous so in
english english and french please uh you
know i i i wish i knew um you know i
think about it we talk about it becoming
endemic and endemic means there's going
to be a certain level of circulation of
the virus but it doesn't mean
good and it doesn't mean that it's only
mild and we don't have to worry about it
covet is going to be one i believe one
of the viruses that we're going to have
to manage along with influenza along
with rsv along with para influenza
on a periodic basis for the foreseeable
future
in a best case scenario if we were all
optimists
it would fade into be more like an
adenovirus or a common cold virus but
it's not there right now
so for the next few months we have a
sense of where we are we have a high
level of immunity we have lots of
antibodies we're giving a boost to
immunity to those who need it most
but i'm also planning for what are the
possible scenarios come
come the fall and what
surveillance measures do we need to have
in place to tell if we're going down
more severe brand new virus versus
less severe
good immunity continuing from the
vaccines that we have so those are the
thought processes that we're going
through right now
i hope we don't have to ever go back to
orders
because that legal
enforceable
order is a last resort in a public
health framework
and it's when we absolutely need to do
that we know a lot more about how we
behave and how that can protect us and
and keep us from getting sick and you
know for people who've not had a cold or
or influenza for the last two years we
we've seen that so we have to take those
all into account
we're not at the point where
we understand that the periodicity and
the changing of this virus so there's
still a lot of uncertainty i think for
another year we'll be in a better place
to understand that in a year but in the
meantime we are in a good place to take
the measures that we uh to to remove
some of the restrictions that we have in
place right now because of the level of
immunity that we have
so i can't predict if it's going to be
better or worse
we've been talking about this globally
as well as you know across the country
and here in bc and
we can look at models we can look at the
potential i think the worst case
scenario
would be if a whole new variant arose
that was a coronavirus that
the vaccine protection didn't
that was able to evade vaccine
protection and was causing more severe
illness than
delta for example
then we would have to look at taking
some of these more drastic measures that
keep people apart and slow down that
transmission until we had a new vaccine
or an effective treatment
but that's like a whole new pandemic
starting
so that's one of the scenarios that we
need to think through
i expect
probably will be somewhere in the middle
and that will need a booster dose at
some point in time for most people
perhaps sooner for those who are more
vulnerable
but there's as i say i don't want to be
ominous we're in a good place now we
need to take advantage of that and we
need to learn about
how to live with covid better and
make sure that we're taking those
precautions that we know work for us
personally and of course to get
vaccinated
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much
we'll see you soon
you